Intro
These days, every movie fan knows the one
word that can spell disaster, or pull of a
miracle:reshoots. But reshoots are a lot
more common than you might think. And even
if some tend to be exaggerated, there are
plenty of hit movies that really WERE drastically
changed due to studio concerns, or saved by
a director's second pass. Here are 10 Movies
Completely Transformed By Reshoots.
Thor: The Dark World
It may not be Marvel's biggest hit, but ask
fans of the second Thor movie what saved the
day, and they'll probably agree it had a lot
to do with Tom Hiddleston's Loki playing a
major role. From the opening scenes that pick
up right after Avengers, to Loki's impression
of Captain America, he made sure to deliver
the best laughs, and help set off the ultra-stoic
Thor. But nearly all of those scenes were
added for fear it was getting a bit dry - and
were just a few of the many action scenes
heightened to keep things moving.
I Am Legend
It might be the most famous example of a re-shot
ending that actually got things completely
wrong. The original ending for this tale of
a vampie-zombie apocalypse was a shocker,
revealing that the monsters weren't just intelligent,
but willing to let the hero live if he returned
the leader's mate. But that ending - which
saw mankind basically drop down the food chain
- got the studio nervous. Instead, an ending
was reshot to have the hero find a cure, then
blow everyone up. Basically, the opposite
message - and an ending few fans would actually
have chosen.
Mad Max: Fury Road
George Miller relied on action and landscapes,
more than dialogue to build his post-apocalyptic
world, and - no surprise - the studio had
a hard time seeing what he did. Once he turned
in his first cut, Warner Bros. was blown away.
So impressed, they agreed to give Miller the
extra money needed to film the scenes from
the script that they had forced him to cut:
the opening and closing sequences set in Immortan
Joe's massive Citadel. It's hard to imagine
the film without those landmarks, which is
probably a sign that the studio made the right
call, giving Miller the reshoots needed to
bring his ENTIRE vision to life.
World War Z
There was a time when the Brad Pitt zombie
thriller was marketed as the first of a franchise...
but all that changed when the movie started
nearing its big conclusion. While most of
the movie was a character drama, the original
ending would have sent Pitt's character into
a massive zombie battle in Russia, before
he made it to the Siberian coast, and set
out with medieval weaponry to rescue his family
in America. The studio got cold feet, and
shut down production completely. In the end,
a completely different, smaller, andcheaperthird
act was written and shot.
Superman 2
Director Richard Donner's Superman is hailed
by many as the best film version the world
has seen, so it was no surprise the studio
chose to film its sequel back-to-back to cut
costs. But the legendary director was at odds
with the producers from the start. So when
Superman became a hit, they cut him loose,
figuring he was no longer needed. Richard
Lester was brought in to replace him, and
began re-shooting nearly the entire movie
to remove Donner's directing credit. The dumb
jokes are a sign of the humor Lester went
for, but fans still wonder what could have
been...
Back to the Future
There's a difference between reshooting scenes
and reshooting amovie- and Back to the
Future was practically the latter. Director
Robert Zemeckis knew as soon as the cameras
started rolling that Eric Stoltz, cast as
Marty McFly, wasn't the right kind of funny
for the movie's tone. But knowing Michael
J. Fox's schedule wouldn't be open for weeks,
they kept on rolling - doing their best to
shoot around Stoltz so Fox's shots could be
inserted later. When he became available,
the switch was made - along with movie history.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
The modern reboot of the classic comic mutants
took a crazy twist on the villain Shredder,
but would you believe that he almost wasn't
included in the movie? The original version
of the movie used business mogul Eric Sacks
as the Shredder hiding in plain sight, but
when fans flipped over Iron Man 3 revealing
a fake Mandarin, the producers realized they
were basically pulling the same twist. Reacting
fast, the new Shredder was added, and fans
were none the wiser.
Fantastic Four
There are times when reshoots can hurt a movie,
and times when they just plain ruin it. That's
probably the case with Josh Trank's "Fantastic
Four" reboot, with the first trailer promising
a blend of sci-fi and horror in a genre filled
with popcorn action. The first act of the
movie follows through, but soon after, the
changes and reshoots reported to be demanded
by Fox start to show. It's hard to know if
Trank gave star Kate Mara the fakest wig we've
ever seen for her reshoots so fans could tell
how far the film strayed (you can use all
kinds of clips from the third act, because
it's all wig). Trank and the cast have all
claimed the original cut was the better one,
which means we'll probably never get to see
it.
Finding Nemo
Okay, so you can't technically reshoot a CG
animated film, but Pixar's insane hit Finding
Nemo could have turned out completely different,
since the role of Marlin - Nemo's dad, and
the movie's star - was originally completely
voiced by actor William H. Macy. Pixar's bosses
sensed it wasn't quite working, and Albert
Brooks was brought in instead. Since Brooks'
performance is a major reason the film works
as well as it does, Macy's role, no matter
how good, would have resulted in a different
star, and a different movie.
Men in Black
Everyone knows the movie's story, but it changed
even after key scenes had been filmed. For
starters, the two aliens who meet on Earth
to make sure the "galaxy on Orion's belt"
is safe? They were originally enemy races,
trading the galaxy to end an ancient war between
them - with the movie's villain wanting it
to continue. When the story changed, the entire
scene - performed in English - was dubbed
over in alien, with completely different subtitles.
It's also a talking pug who lays out the plot
- the new one, since his lines were completely
re-written after the scenes had been shot.
BONUS:
Suicide Squad/Rogue One
Just because a movie has yet to be released,
that doesn't mean fans aren't ready to shout
disaster or just celebrate. When DC's Batman
V Superman took hits from critics over its
dark, not-so-fun story, one word of reshoots
on Suicide Squad was all some needed to call
it damage control, claiming new scenes were
being filmed to lighten the mood and add humor.
The cast and director laughed off that story,
claiming the studio was so impressed, they'd
been given the chance to add even more action
- meaning the bad news was... good, actually.
The same happened when Star Wars: Rogue One
added reshoots, with claims that half the
movie was being remade and rewritten, and
director Gareth Edwards replaced - all shot
down just as soon as they were made. We'll
just have to wait and see...
Those are just a handful of movies that prove
a director's second shot at delivering a hit
can be exactly what's needed, or all it takes
to kill any chance it ever had. The producers
and directors behind the decision seem to
be right as often as they're wrong, but can
you think of some examples that we've overlooked?
Make sure to let us know in the comments,
and subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!